[Music]
who Christopher Robin
you and McGregor is Christopher Robin
who reunites with his beloved childhood
friends from the Hundred Acre Wood it's
lovely I mean we just we we had such a
lovely experience making the movie and I
feel like they were present the
creatures you know we had we had
finished versions of them all but they
were of course motionless they were just
stuffed teddy bears but we had them on
set and we would play scenes with them
and then they would remove the teddy
bear and we would play the scenes two
different versions of them that the
special effects people needed the visual
effects people needed but there was
still a sort of memory of them having
been there and and that his little face
Pooh and it was so I got so fond of
acting with him as little eyes and so
when when I watched the film the first
time when he's actually talking back to
me and speaking there there's a big big
moment cracked I don't see any cracks a
few wrinkles
maybe Ewan is no stranger to acting
opposite animated characters his role as
obi-wan Kenobi in the Star Wars prequel
trilogy it gave him plenty of practice
what's this a local there's often an
actor reading the lines in and if you
were acting with Pooh has meant to be
here and they were there you tend to
look at well I remember in Star Wars
there was a well with Georgia with Ahmed
best to play Jar Jar he he had a helmet
and then Chargers eyes were up here and
but it was impossible to not look at his
eyes so they put a screen they put like
a screen but it was like one-way glass
so he could see us like sunglasses we
couldn't see him just so we can't
remember think up you know
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]